[Musica]
mi presento appunto anche se mi ha già
presentato mi chiamo filippo giordano o
di ciò ha 19 anni ha classe 2002 e vengo
da bassano del grappa in provincia di
vicenza
e sono qui per parlarvi appunto della
mia storia della storia della nostra
vera mia associazione che ho fondato a
18 anni quindi l'anno scorso mentre
ancora erano i banchi della mia scuola
ho fondato questa associazione
appunto per rispondere a un quesito che
mi sono posto dopo aver visto appunto
come diceva prima jurassic park
mi sono chiesto ma è veramente possibile
riportare in vita specie estinte come si
vede nel film
da quel momento ho cominciato a fare
ricerche sia sul web che su riviste su
libri
e ho cominciato a rendermi conto che
quella fantascienza che noi abbiamo
visto durante il film quanti di voi ha
visto jurassic park
ecco la maggior parte delle persone in
questa stanza
quella fantascienza che noi vediamo nel
film può diventare una scienza reale
nella realtà è questa associazione nasce
si chiama ingen
progetto d'estinzione e nasce appunto
per fare ricerca e sviluppo nel campo
della d'estinzione e creare prodotti
e dispositivi per dare la possibilità di
appunto riportare in vita specie estinte
questa diciamo è la nostra associazione
l'abbiamo fondata come ho detto un anno
fa è la prima volta che ci siamo come da
studenti ci siamo
visti
abbiamo visto la necessità di fare delle
carte di andare all'agenzia delle
entrate di stipulare è uno statuto un
atto costitutivo è da lì abbiamo
cominciato ad essere piccoli
imprenditori cominciare a fare quello il
prodotto che noi poi abbiamo sviluppato
diciamo è uno strumento che ho pensato
io mentre facevo studi sull'embrione
nesi degli uccelli
l'embriogenesi degli uccelli e lo studio
delle embriogenesi e cioè lo studio
della formazione dell'embrione si vede
all'interno
in questo caso io facevo studi sulla
osservazione degli uccelli
si vedeva appunto l'embrione crescere
ogni giorno tirando fuori un nuovo
dall'incubatrice rompendolo uccidendo
purtroppo l'embrione perché questa
pratica
che ancora si usa porta alla morte
l'embrione però permette di visualizzare
tutti gli step del dell'embrione però in
modo molto superficiale
e da lì mi sono chiesto se fosse
possibile
evitare la morte dell'embrione e creare
un qualcosa che potesse che potesse
sostituire nuovo naturale con qualcosa
di artificiale che possa far continuare
la crescita dell'embrione fino alla
nascita del pulcino in questo caso
perché facevo studi su
su embrioni di gallina
ecco la grande domanda come dicevo prima
si possono riportare in vita specie
estinte poi ne riparleremo da lì a
distanza di un anno abbiamo cominciato a
studiare questa tecnica che si chiama
appunto
la tecnica della crescita in vitro di
embrioni di animali
e da lì abbiamo cominciato a
sperimentare alcuni oggetti
abbiamo cominciato a usare della
plastica
dopodiché abbiamo adottato la stampa 3d
per raggiungere questo obiettivo
l'obiettivo era creare il primo uovo
artificiale universale stampato in 3d
cioè cosa significa un nuovo artificiale
che permettesse la crescita all'interno
di esso di embrioni di specie o vi pare
quindi di specie che si riproducono
tramite la produzione di uova per
esempio rettili uccelli anfibi pesci
eccetera
per dare un enorme contributo alla
ricerca
perché è un enorme passo avanti poter
osservare ad occhio nudo perché questo
uovo artificiale si chiama cgia è
l'acronimo di capsula germinale
artificiale è totalmente trasparente
quindi c'è la totale visibilità
dell'uovo e dell'embrione che cresce si
vede il battito cardiaco si vedono i
vasi sanguigni le coronarie si vede
tutto ad occhio nudo senza l'uso di
nessuno strumento che possa andare a
disturbare o a far male all'embrione
andando avanti ci siamo resi conto che
questo
questo mio quesito
sul riportare in vita specie estinte
avevamo già un prodotto che poteva
aiutare questo campo cioè la cgia la
cgia la capsula cioè chiamiamolo
artificiale è molto più semplice
da la possibilità di avere un nuovo alle
specie estinte cioè nel campo nella
fantascienza c'è jurassic park con
riportare in vita i dinosauri nella
realtà esiste la scienza della
d'estinzione la distinzione è un ramo
dell'ingegneria genetica che permette di
riportare in vita un individui estinto
tramite il suo patrimonio genetico
come si vede su jurassic park no su
jurassic park ci sono gli scienziati del
parco che tramite le zanzare che avevano
punto un dinosauro e che sono rimaste
invischiate nell'ambra prelevano il
sangue il dinosauro
dove all'interno c'è il suo codice
genetico lo mettono all'interno di un
uovo di struzzo e fanno nascere un
dinosauro
ecco nella realtà non è così semplice
purtroppo è anche fortunatamente in
alcuni casi
ma comunque il concetto è molto simile
c'è la necessità di avere
un codice genetico c'è necessità di
avere materiale genetico per poter
effettuare una d'estinzione quindi si
preleva il materiale genetico della
specie da distinguere ce ne sono
tantissime che si sono estinti negli
ultimi anni negli ultimi giorni anche
oggi una specie o due si sting wer hanno
purtroppo la media è molto alta delle
estinzioni
posso fare l'esempio magari tutti
conoscerete il dodo che conosce il dodo
conosciamo tutti il dodo il dodo
ci sono altri animali come il tilacino
che era un marsupiale
australiano era era simile a un canide a
un cane poi abbiamo anche il moa che un
enorme struzzo alto quasi quattro metri
che si è istinto in nuova zelanda per
via della caccia incontrollata
queste principali specie che noi abbiamo
l'ambizione
ecco ecco qui abbiamo il dodo e qui il
tirocinio sembra quasi un cane una volpe
e tigrato è un marsupiale
ai canguri
e si è estinto a causa della caccia
incontrollata dell'uomo si credeva che
questa specie mangiasse tutto il pollame
e tutto quanto ma non è stato mai
diciamo non ci sono state mai le prove
per per dire che era così però comunque
l'hanno cacciato fino alla morte fino
agli anni
cinquanta agli anni 60 come vedete ci
abbiamo comunque delle fotografie in
bianco e nero di questo animale non è
una ricostruzione a differenza del dodo
il moa invece che questo struzzo
gigantesco che si è estinto in nuova
zelanda si istinto intorno al 1500
perché sono importanti le date a
differenza di jurassic park che per
riportare in vita un dinosauro bisogna
andare almeno a 66 milioni di anni fa 66
milioni di anni fa per il dna sono
tantissimi anni è difficile recuperare
del patrimonio genetico del dna da un da
un fossile vecchio 66 milioni di anni
mentre su un fossile per esempio del moa
vecchio 521 anni che in confronto era
anche a un milione di anni e pochissimo
si può
riportarlo in vita si può rimetterlo
nella nell'ecosistema e riacquisti
riacquisire l'equilibrio che questo
animale aveva nel suo ambiente
e importante anche parlare di animali
estinti perché non si parla solo di per
esempio quando si è estinto il dodo non
si estinto solo il dodo si parla di
estinzioni a catena perché gli animali
tra di loro hanno un legame anche se non
si vede anche se sembra tra predatori e
prede comunque hanno un legame nel
questo sistema che contribuiscono per
mantenere un equilibrio
per esempio il dodo si nutriva di una
pianta specifica che
mangiando la e mantenendosi semi dentro
il suo stomaco andava a piantare faceva
gli diciamo giardiniere di questa pianta
e andava con le sue feci a far crescere
questa pianta in giro per il suo
ecosistema
e questa pianta era cibo di una
testuggine era cibo i frutti di questa
pianta era cibo di un uccello
e con l'estinzione del dodo c'è stata
questa assenza è questa assenza
praticamente ha portato all'estinzione
della testuggine e questa è stata per
colpa dell'uomo per l'uomo il dodo non è
stato cacciato più di tanto si è stato
cacciato
il motivo dell'estinzione anche quello
ma è soprattutto per l'introduzione di
animali estranei nel suo ecosistema come
polli maiali e questi hanno portato
anche malattie che il dodo nella sua ex
nel suo ecosistema che è sempre stato
incontaminato tra virgolette da parte di
patogeni portati da l'uomo ha cominciato
a risentirne è fino all'estinzione
e questo ha portato all'estinzione del
doodle estinzione della testuggine è
l'estinzione anche dell'uccello che si
nutriva di frutti di questa pianta che
la tartaruga e il dodo di cui si
nutrivano e anche questo uccello si
estinto ed è tutta una catena
estinguendosi questo cielo che mangiava
la pia i frutti di questa pianta che
magari volando aveva una diciamo un'area
più ampia di piantare queste piante
altri animali si sono estinti quindi non
si parla solo di pochi animali che si
sono estinti istinto il dodo il tilacino
o il moa sono tre quale una decina
all'incirca le ne abbiamo fatto
estinguere in verità ne abbiamo fatti
estinguere centinaia e con l'estinzione
di centinaia di specie
l'equilibrio degli ecosistemi non è più
come prima
ci sono dei problemi
la deforestazione
e tutto questo porta a
specie che magari prevalgono per esempio
i cinghiali noi abbiamo in italia il
problema di cinghiali che sono diciamo
una popolazione è troppo ampia e in
altri posti possono essere altri piccoli
animali che con la mancanza di predatori
come le tigri che sono in pericolo in
alcuni posti del mondo in mancanza di
predatori questi cominciano a riprodursi
e l'equilibrio si spacca e quell
ecosistema non è più con come lavoro lo
conoscevamo e diventa un ecosistema con
un problema che bisognerà risolvere e
noi abbiamo da qualche anno la potenza
diciamo genetica per risolvere questi
problemi per poter riportare in vita
specie estinte
il nostro obiettivo con l'associazione
oltre fino adesso abbiamo creato questo
primo uomo artificiale stampato in 3d
dove abbiamo fatto nascere eva lei eva
ed è il primo essere vivente al mondo
nato da un nuovo artificiale e stampato
in 3d
questo è un enorme successo per la
nostra organizzazione
è né un del neo enorme passo avanti per
le biotecnologie nel mondo perché con
questa tecnica si dà un enorme
contributo anche alla ricerca
biomedicale con con questa tecnica si
possono studiare malattie coronariche
malattie cardiovascolari neurologiche
si può oltre appunto al suo vero
utilizzo che quello della d'estinzione
cioè dare un nuovo alle specie estinte
l'obiettivo appunto della nostra adesso
associazione futura start up innovativa
e dare ed essere la prima ad una delle
prime aziende al mondo ad essere al
servizio della natura della biodiversità
dell'equilibrio tra gli ecosistemi
riportando in vita specie estinte un po
come si vede su jurassic park tranne
senza dinosauri o velociraptor che
scappano da recinti eccetera
e la distinzione cosa porterebbe
oltre al
appunto la specie riportata in vita
porterebbe a innovazione scientifica
riporterebbe porterebbe alcuni animali
che muore noi abbiamo istinto magari nel
1500 all'interno del loro sangue
potevano avere un neo
una molecola che noi possiamo utilizzare
come cura per qualche malattia
e tutto questo la d'estinzione
porterebbe un enorme progresso
scientifico tecnico e tecnologico oltre
a un enorme progresso nella natura e
nella biodiversità e nella sua
sua interezza
porterebbe appunto a questi nuovi rami
della scienza e porterebbe un enorme
progresso nel nel mondo enel
dell'essere umano oltre perché della
natura grazie
[Applauso]